thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a very
personal wild ride with Stevo I get
extremely vulnerable on this episode and
and it's pretty juicy too so strap on
your seat belts for some uh insight into
uh like the BAM situation I kind of got
fed up with like misinformation and I
might have overshared about what really
happened you know I also uh just come
clean about a bunch of stuff I really
really clean my closet on this episode
and boy do I go on the biggest rant ever
ah man at the end stick around to the
end for this one because it is a rant
and a half
um I just really want to express my
gratitude to all of you and with that
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen me I'm getting some
stuff off my chest dudes and I think
this might be the most juicy one it's
also been like on my mind for a long
long time that hey what if we did a
podcast without a guest
and I've been scared to do that but I've
also been utterly overwhelmed with
anxiety over the booking of the guests
and now I'm just gonna gonna do this
because I've got so much that I want to
admit that I want to just get off my
chest I want to look back on this last
year I want to look forward towards 2023
so let's get into it yeah what's number
one for you to get off your chest this
year
um I've been
suffering with my mental health over
really was one comment that I that I saw
online and
um there there have been others like it
but the the comment was
I used to really like your content Stevo
uh until you became a money hungry c
word I don't want to get the it's coming
to c word and I was like you know I
thought well that's kind of a nasty
thing I think I might have blocked the
guy
but the thing is that jokes are funny
when there's an element of Truth and
negative comments are hurtful when
there's an element of Truth and and I
really feel that I've done myself a
disservice
by being overly aggressive in soliciting
like merge sales buy this you know buy
that like I think that there is a a
fairly large contingent of my audience
that it's just like ah man you know like
you're always always trying to get me to
give you money you know and um
I'm not saying that that's a wrong thing
I mean who isn't trying to get the bag
but I think that I want to be a little
bit deliberate about taking my foot off
the gas and that's with promoting
products not like I mean like like it's
whatever it's just a general Vibe you
know like I'm a content creator I love
attention I love making videos and in my
defense with all the promotion like the
promoting stuff that I do I build that
promotion into awesome videos you know
like so like whatever and I'm not gonna
stop trying to be successful and I've
got a bunch of people who work for me I
have a lot of employees it's crazy and
um I've got a lot of businesses and not
all the businesses are like super
killing it you know like they need
promotion yeah but you're also saving up
for an animal sanctuary too so it's like
you gotta Tap Out of You Gotta you know
squeeze out the equity at some point
sure sure and again I'm just I'm just
acknowledging it that uh
you know that one comment
I like I think that they're like the
comments on this are gonna like that
there's gonna be a big thing of where
people agree with it and and a lot of
people aren't going to care but now
here's the thing
is that
you're never gonna make everybody happy
there's always gonna be somebody that's
got some nasty thing to say and there's
gonna be legitimately people who have
different perspectives on it you know
it's not something what I'm talking
about isn't something that bothers
everybody and like
whatever I can't care what other people
think and let that motivate me and how I
want to be what I do care about and why
I'm speaking up about this is because
it's what I think like I I feel like
I've kind of
acted like somebody who's a greedy guy
wants to make as much money as possible
and of course everybody wants to make as
much money as possible like it's human
nature to to want to earn and provide
and like my whole career
is not it's my my career has always been
something that is tenuous precarious
like you're in the spotlight and it's
just like all being in the spotlight
does is create this sense of anxiety
about how the spotlight's gonna go away
and I've I've hustled I've hustled and
I've strived and I've worked and I've
kept this ridiculous career of mine
going for over 20 [__] years and
that's epic and I still have that
anxiety the spotlight's gonna go away I
gotta hurry up and and strike while the
iron's hot but enough enough with that
I just want to
put out content and and have people feel
good about I'm here to serve them with
entertaining stuff and it doesn't always
have to be like give me your money now
on the same topic as it relates to the
podcast every podcast has sponsors you
know any podcaster so I don't have any
bad feelings and we're going to promote
stuff with this podcast yeah we're gonna
have sponsors for this podcast I don't
feel bad about that at all skip through
the ad Roots if you don't want to listen
to them jump on the deals if you want to
if you want to get the deals because
it's all pretty cool stuff that we offer
and it's also sometimes important stuff
that we offer which is why this episode
is brought to you by better help now let
me tell you this I couldn't have gotten
this vulnerable gotten this honest
called myself out if I hadn't spoken up
about that it was bothering me in the
first place and I can't say it enough
that it's important for people to speak
up when things are bothering them and
that's what being in therapy is all
about now if you believe me then good
because better help is the way to get
into therapy so easily and simply
they've matched up over three million
people with licensed professional
therapists it's so easy you can match up
with specifically the therapists that
specialized in the issues that you're
looking for help with and it all happens
online so you don't have to go to any
like awkward office or dude it's just
super simple and super easy and if you
go to better help that's better h e l
p.com slash Stevo you're going to get 10
off your first month and already the
prices are every bit as friendly as the
service I mean you can't do better and I
love being in therapy it helps me I'd
love for it to help you so once again go
to betterhelp.com
Stevo for 10 off your first month now
let's get back to this juicy podcast
yeah when I think too like uh you know
we we spoke about you know doing some
cool [__] for the people that are
listening to this podcast for sure and
uh so what am I going to do about it
what am I going to do what am I going to
make it right okay the the first thing
is I'm gonna
unveil uh a refreshed stevo.com and the
first thing at the top of the page
before there's anything for sale it's
gonna be my last comedy special with no
paywall whatsoever completely free I'd
like it to be downloadable as well as
streamable and I kind of kicked myself
for having been uh
like so so aggressive about promoting go
to the paywall and and
I just I I did myself a disservice
because a lot more people would have
seen that comedy special and I'm really
proud of it man that the gnarly special
was epic and if you haven't seen it [__]
dude by the time this goes up tomorrow
we should have that ready [__]
streaming for free so when they go so
[__] right now like we're gonna make
that happen right now it's free
streaming so I can watch my gnarly
special so the people that are listening
to this or they have the first access to
know that you have a brand new website
and I don't know that the website is
going to be ready to be but launched
yeah all right well either way whether
it's a new website or not it sounds like
it probably is gnarly's [__] free no
it's [__] free yeah that's cool and
then uh also and it's not on YouTube
because it's not allowed on YouTube
because it's full of [__] [__] that
YouTube will delete the [__] out of my
channel for because it's so explicit
yeah go ahead well though that's cool
and then you know while in the spirit of
giving stuff away
you want to give some more stuff away I
think I I want to give all kinds of [__]
away I think sprinkled throughout this
episode we can we could do cool [__]
like that we've just given away gnarly
all right well then what about what do
you think about on the website if they
get the Stevo P all the pins
p-i-n-s on your website if people are
like into putting pins on like jackets
and bags and stuff but there's a weird
like thing people like people like to
collect them so why don't we make those
zero dollars so zero zero dollars for
Pins we have three different kinds of
pins there's the firecracker up the butt
pin there's the uh uh classic Stevo yeah
logo pen and there's a Johnny O pin yeah
so but that's sort of like uh not that
great of a thing because yeah the pins
are free but you got to pay for the
shipping yeah and let me ask you why the
[__] is shipping costs so much
I think because of like the supply chain
the gas prices are high and it's just
like
it's always been that way and I think
the answer is that we're not Amazon
we're not that [__] big that we can
make shipping that [__] cheap and
Amazon doesn't even necessarily make it
that cheap do they yeah they're that big
when I ship hot sauce out to like let's
say I have 48 hot sauces that I'm
shipping to Amazon right if I were to do
that with like UPS or whatever like 30
pounds of it it would cost like 30 to 40
bucks when I buy this the labels through
Amazon 13 bucks
I mean they just have the [__]
Monopoly on shipping it's nice so
they're just that big and any situation
outside of Amazon is gonna be like super
expensive shipping and that's just the
reality of the world it's the reality
because sometimes like
somebody will order something and they
live in the outskirts and so to get a to
get they have a we'll pay one price and
then all of a sudden we lose money
because there's a nine dollar surcharge
because they don't get shipments every
day and and shipping to Europe and
Australia even Canada is just uh I mean
shipping shipping the skateboard to
Australia costs like 70 bucks
gnarly and that's like cost but we've
got an Amazon going on Australia now
we're going to Australia so that's cool
we're gonna like man and thank you
Australia this tour is going to be so
epic starting February 17th yeah oh man
I can't wait to come to Australia but
enough of that if you want free pins
you're gonna have to pay for shipping
it's like what it's kind of if you're in
America six seven bucks six or seven
bucks it's free pens also I think we
should give away some shot glasses
all right
I feel like we're bogging people down
with like uh all right well then we
could talk about that later but then
shot glasses will be zero dollars okay
so at the top of the website it's going
to say pin zero dollars shot glasses is
zero dollars all right cool
um yeah right you seemed like you're
upset about that I'm not upset about it
I just don't wanna bore people with with
business when like I was just talking
about not doing that well we're giving
it up for free giving away [__] for free
is fun maybe we should be wearing Santa
hats yeah stocking stuffers I mean
moving on
um I uh
I want to
acknowledge uh the absence of The
Gorgeous Paul Briskey everybody always
asks what happened to Paul what happened
to Papa Paul
I think everybody knows this because we
were so a candid about it Paul has made
great efforts to uh in fact he was
trying to move to Arizona like he's he
has delayed moving to Arizona but he
might as well be in Arizona because he's
almost never in America I mean maybe not
almost never but he travels so much he
travels so much that uh I just got to a
point where hey man like you're gone so
much of the time I don't want it to be
jarring I want to have consistency
so Paul's still on the team he he edited
he's listening right now listening right
now he edits everything and to his
credit
he's really stepped up our game because
he got this software that he can control
the computer in our editing Bay
with all of the media that we've got a
lot of media in there and he can control
it from anywhere in the world and by
gosh dang darn it does he control it
from all over the world because he's
always traveling somewhere else well
he's traveling because he's working on
his music he's working on his music and
and bless his heart there's not one
little part of me that will ever
discourage somebody from pursuing their
dreams it's just a bummer because he's
so [__] good at what he does so good
at what he did he's so good at what he
does but so anyway so valuable and bless
him he's he's traveling around pursuing
his dreams and while he's doing that
he's he's editing for us uh remotely
yeah and a lot of the time he is home
and and when he is home he's at the
house in the edit Bay and you know I
just don't have the heart to to have him
like
ultimately move away he's gonna
ultimately move away permanently he's
gonna be gone like most of the time like
and and to have sometimes is here and
sometimes he's not it just doesn't make
sense to me I want to have consistency
yeah I mean if you're and if you're a
Paul fan that kid is you you can go
listen to it absolutely support Paul we
love Paul's music I love Paul and um you
know well in his absence we have Vinnie
over here Vinnie over here
Vinnie was on the Zach podcast and I
want to acknowledge that because I've
been pretty disciplined like I said
about just staying away from looking at
comments it it messes me up I wish I was
more like Dana White who's literally
unfazed by like anything bro the
comments that I get on there are just
like damn Scott got fat they're like
damn dude that profile Pig you're a
catfish and I'm like God damn it dude
that's why I lost a lot of weight
because I was like this some of these
are true like I got a little [__]
heavy I lost a lot of weight I recently
gained a little bit back but uh you know
I mean the comments suck and uh you know
again they hurt when they're true and
and bro
yeah you're looking bro you're fat dude
you're putting away like that you know
the and and whatever you know that
that's not that time you being mean or
that's I can't do anything in moderation
I can't eat like a normal person
like drink like a normal person so like
yeah I acknowledge that but it's it's
you know I'm working on it guys be nice
but right [__] it dude there was a point
where you recently lost a bunch away and
looked phenomenally good looks so good I
lost 30 pounds and then I gained 15 back
in like two months I
um have had two friends in my life where
like you go around with them and chicks
just are losing their mind they're
having like a [__] mental breakdown
over how attracted somebody they are one
was
um my bro jeffrow in Florida chicks just
could not stand it they were they would
just come up and say oh my God you are
so gorgeous and and you're the other one
wow my sister said
I wish she didn't say it because I could
never [__] I'm here I can never
adhere to my sister said Scott Randolph
is uncomfortably good looking good I'm
beautiful
I was just like I'm sitting here having
trouble breathing because my gut's in my
diaphragm
yeah I mean dude it's like uh it's
gnarly man I know it's Comfort eating
but uh I'm working on it and uh I'm
really sorry I let everybody down
hey can we open up the door because this
is [__] hot
um I can't so I meant to bring this up
we had Vinnie on the uh the Zach podcast
and I had good discipline I didn't look
at any comments on the Zack podcast but
both Vinnie and Scott Randolph both of
you told me that the comments were
overwhelmingly brutal saying that like
that I was bullying Zach if there was a
thousand comments 997 of them were like
uh Jesus you know did anybody else feel
like terrible for Zach too or you know
like he's like a bully it was it was
tough it was tough but the thing is was
like dude I'm I'm really like you know
susceptible to people's feelings and
emotions and we never want to bum
anybody out we always ask people if we
want to cut something because we don't
ever want to [__] yeah like hurt
anybody what was most important was that
afterwards his act was that or was
everything okay said yeah everything was
great I loved it you know I didn't think
that Zach would tell you to take
something out if it bothers me for sure
yeah
can we talk about that beforehand I mean
whatever you know like he he he spoke up
about certain things he was sensitive
about ahead of time and uh there's
certain things we didn't did
that we didn't talk about but I didn't
think that we were that mean that when I
was reading the comments I was like
dude we'll read that [__] mean here's
here's the thing when you guys told me
that the comments were that negative on
the Zach podcast I started really
spending about it because I'm the same
way man I'm not I don't want to bum
people out like I don't want to be a
mean guy I don't want to be a bully so
it was it was really bothering me and
what I did was uh reached out to our bro
Tommy who in our videos we call him
Super Bro Super Bro Tommy's a guy who uh
was my first ever sponsor XYZ that was
Zach's first sponsor like Tommy is he
came to visit me in rehab when I first
got sober and he really helped me get
sober he's a mentor to us in in sobriety
and the skateboard culture like he's
like he's on speed dial I have like very
few people on my my favorites my speed
dial and Tommy's on there and he's not
an important person and like a lot of
people's lives very much so very
important person in a bunch of people's
lives he's also a a very
like reasonable in some cases
and he's definitely a sober guy who
practices the principles of of
spirituality and and so I reached out to
Tommy I said hey man like uh can you
listen to the zag podcast and tell me
what you think
and he uh
again he's been intimately involved in
the entire relationship with Zach from
the start Tommy said dude I just uh
finished listening to the podcast and I
didn't see anything wrong with it it was
just a bunch of guys
uh telling a crazy story about you know
how things went down
um and and I wanna okay just watch the
whole Zack episode on wild ride and it
was awesome I didn't see anything that
was uncool or mean to Zach just a few
Bros telling funny stories about how the
[__] went down this episode is good for
Zach and all the things he is working on
[__] the crybabies that talk [__] I
loved it and stoked to see bat Zach back
on track and headed in the right
direction see I think the problem is all
the viewers they don't know they only
know what they see on on the podcast so
they don't really know the dynamic of
the relationship and what is going on
behind closed doors and and uh and the
reality is that our relationship with
Zach it's impossible to characterize our
relationship and keep everything fluffy
and positive because it's been a rough
road super rough yeah it's been a rough
road and I think that uh we're all okay
with that you know like we're all okay
with the fact that it's been a rough
rough time yeah and uh I think that
being candid about how rough of a road
it was made a lot of people
uncomfortable for sure and um
you know I I'm sensitive to that
particularly because
podcasting
it
reveals who you really are 100 there's
no way around that like like what you're
doing is you're putting out
a completely unedited
conversation and I think that's why it's
such a crazy phenomenon because people
they're literally yeah a fly on the wall
people are absolutely like just in the
room with you there's no editing you
cannot pretend to be somebody that
you're not for these extended periods of
time and put out the unedited everything
and and hold up in front people are
gonna find out who you are and that is a
blessing and a curse because I pride
myself like crazy
on being
like a guy that doesn't have see I don't
have to filter myself I don't have to
like look around and before I say
something because generally like I don't
like you know I'm not a bad guy and I
love the fact that I can put out a
podcast every week and like not think
like oh man what did I say like do I
have should I have to go back and edit
something out like I'm an unfiltered guy
that's the blessing the curse is that I
don't know how to shut up I genuinely do
[__] talk all over people all the
time all of that criticism is legit my
only defense is that I'm getting a
little better
sometimes before I go into a podcast I
think I'm going to shut up and listen
and I actually pull it off like with
Bruce Buffer
sometimes I don't remember to think that
but I think I get better and and I think
the podcast is successful
largely because when you watch these
podcasts regularly you see like what
kind of a guy I am and even though I
interrupt people and talk over them and
[__] I'm like yeah that's how you are
in real life
yeah like I mean you know it's just how
I am you know but I'm not a bad guy and
I think that's why and at the end of the
day that's all that matters right is
that you're just not a bad guy yeah so
it does upset me that people thought
that that I was a bad guy to Zach
you know and I wanted to acknowledge
that I think you take the like even with
like poopies and Zach like you take the
mentor role as an older brother because
it's kind of that's a that's a good
point man I beat up on them you beat up
on them like an older brother because
like there was a situation when some guy
came over here and he was taking
advantage of poopies like you were like
get this guy the [__] out of here yeah
and like I've never seen you like that
and and it was like you know and and I
looked over at poopies and he was just
kind of like I was like oh dude Steve's
like an older brother like bro the guy
was taking advantage of him clearly and
you were like bro wait a minute are you
telling me that you're doing this X Y
and Z and the guy was like well yeah and
Steve's like we can help him out way
better than that like and he you were so
[__] pissed right and and I beat up
on the guys because I'm you know I want
them to be doing better you know I want
them to be kicking ass and I'm like dude
what like what is this you know like get
get your act together and take advantage
of the opportunity you have and let me
help you do it and [__] let's go yeah
and I think with Zach too I saw some
comments that people were like you know
all you had to do was click the button
if I can to accept it's like okay what
the what they don't understand on the
back story was is like dude we built him
a website we got him the name change we
told all that but but maybe we did but
yeah and and a lot of people are
probably like yeah pat yourself on the
back some more like it really takes the
benefit out of like doing something nice
to help someone if you're gonna get on a
microphone and brag about it but I'm
just saying I think where we're coming
from is like frustrating because it's
like bro Zach you try to help you we try
to help you we did everything we [__]
could but whenever I mean and and again
like maybe that makes people
uncomfortable but but like once again
we're revealing ourselves for for who we
really are and and I mean it seemed like
we were beating up on them yeah we
probably were because we want him to to
be killing it yeah we want to help them
and and it's frustrating when when you
know like so hey I'm guilty of wanting
better for Zach I'm guilty of it too and
how I'm gonna make it right is I'm gonna
give away a pair of shoes because I
became a sneaker head recently I don't
even know I don't even know I don't even
know what shoes I bought but uh which
shoes did I buy you bought a pair of
Jordan one highs and he's black and
yellow welcome yellow Jordan one highs I
don't have social media but if you can
find a way to get a hold of me and
you're a size 12 I will send you the
Jordan black and yellow let me ask you
this yeah does you get an on and off of
social media
is there any correlation between that
and where you're at with your weight
no
not at all okay I I got off social media
for a lot of reasons you're damn well on
social media when you just lost anyway
but but I got on to promote the The
Perfect Chaos the documentary I did and
then it you know I don't even know what
the numbers were that it did but I'm
going to put it on YouTube for free too
just because that's like my you know my
biggest work but dude when I got on
social media it's like did the amount of
people that reach out to me just to get
a hold of you and like then all of a
sudden like I'm I'm involved in drama
that it's like it's not the real world
and I was like all right I just bought a
house there's there's a lot of goals
that I want and I'm just like I'm just
gonna completely just focus on
everything and just because before I met
you I wasn't on social media right okay
and it's just kind of like I don't know
all right so we not like I think that
was uh that was a definite non-apology
on the Zach
I wasn't seeking to apologize I was just
trying to explain the the dynamic of the
situation and Zach's okay with it I've
talked to him since like I love Zach you
called Zach after and talked to him
about it yeah plus I had other people
reach out and say hey it was great to
see your friendship on display oh wow
Land spang's Group texted us just the
two of us and said hey I was really
stoked to see your friendship on display
so not everybody saw it and by
friendship he means beating up on Zach
I'm an older brother you know but like
uh tough love you know whenever yeah it
was tough and it's love yep so there you
go
um I also caught a bunch of [__] for the
uh the BAM episode but that was a much
more divided thing which which the one
that he did and then the recent one the
recent one why just because and this is
this isn't something that bothers me or
or uh at least the the
comments I saw some comments where
people are like man Stevo is so holier
than now about his uh recovery about his
sobriety and he's talking to Bam like
he's better than bam you know like I
genuinely don't feel that that's the
case and like no I think as somebody
that's committed to the truth like he
was just saying some stuff that weren't
true and you were just like dude that's
not true and for some reason he's like
he like you can call Bam out on his [__]
and he
doesn't [__] like uh he listens to
you
so when he's saying certain things and
you're like well bam dude you feel the
drug like you're not letting him get
away with stuff and I just think that
your commitment to the truth is kind of
you know I
haven't should people like real there
was a bunch of
positive feedback to the BAM episode
there was a bunch of negative feedback
to the BAM episode I'm not concerned
with that you know like like
I I don't think I'm better than than
people like it's not a question of
better you know like it's whatever like
I I I want everything for bam I want I
want to be so jealous of him the way I
used to be again
I I like I just do so and it's tough
love whatever like I don't even know if
it's tough love I just I just [__]
I'm so worried about bam you know I I
think we might be able to uh have this
conversation with bam again
we'll see but um the thing about the and
I didn't even want to apologize or
anything about I don't even want to
explain myself about how I approached
the BAM episode I just want to throw it
out there how wrong people are about
what went on with his guardianship
wow do people get it wrong and like why
what do you what do you what do they
think happened and what's really
happening
because I think we're heading into
something that's going to uh make a
splash but in short let me tell you what
I get wrong about my diet and when I get
right about it I eat a lot of garbage
but what I get right is I use athletic
greens ag1 from athletic greens it's the
most delicious fully comprehensive
totally convenient supplement that you
it's the best start in the morning with
a pint of water put a scoop in or one of
their totally convenient travel packs it
is delicious it's loaded with 75
different vitamins minerals Whole Food
sourced superfoods adaptogens probiotics
it's insane how much healthy good stuff
they pack into this one delicious
supplement I swear by it it's what I do
right with my diet and it helps my gut
health it helps my cognitive ability it
fills in all the gaps in my diet that's
why it's called athletic greens man it's
like getting all the stuff that your
body needs and getting all of it in one
go and just per usual they take care of
the listeners my podcast so if you go to
athletic greens.com
Stevo they will give you with your first
order five free travel packs which have
the full comprehensive convenient
nutrition for a whole day five of them
plus an entire year's supply of immune
boosting vitamin D
it's a great offer jump on it by going
to
athleticgreens.com
Stevo now
Let's uh go new clear with this
the the the the thing that they got
wrong is that the guardianship was some
kind of an exercise in taking advantage
of bam for his money like Britney Spears
you know that's what it was was like
they stripped her of her rights so they
could help themselves to her money
and that is is really not what happened
with with the BAM situation because like
we said all along there really weren't
financial implications in the uh the BAM
guardianship that nobody had the ability
to help themselves to Bam's money so
they're completely off point and there
was
it's probably over sharing but there was
a at uh in the beginning a a certain
amount of money that Bam's family set
aside not to pay for just to pay for the
rehab you know rehab's not free
I'm definitely over sharing her but I'll
just go for it like they they put that
money towards his rehab and Bam was in
rehab for a long time so that got spent
and then after that money ran out
Not only was the guardian not taking
Bam's money the guardian was actually
covering Bam's rehab the guardian put so
much money into that rehab for bam I
don't even know if you want to go there
all right
the guardian okay I'll leave it there
the guardian only put money in
the guardian did not take money out okay
that is what everybody got so terribly
wrong nobody was taking money from bam
over that guardianship they were they
were just sinking money into sinking
their own money into his rehab thank you
for stopping me
where's my
my list okay
um
dude can I just need to put to the
street team I just have the street team
down here what a rip dude at the end of
every episode I uh I acknowledge the
people who stuck around and listened to
the end of the episode
all the way through I call those people
the street team because in the beginning
of the podcast I asked everybody at the
end
to take a screenshot of the podcast
um whether it's on audio or on video and
post that tagging me and the guest
uh and letting them know you know give
love to the guests support to the guest
it was kind of I caught it street team
because it was like Grassroots promotion
if I get people to post screenshots then
you read you know reaching an audience
with like uh support for the podcast
like support for the guests I just
thought it would help everything and
um
there are people who did that and I'm
super grateful for it I had always
acknowledge these people and when I'm on
tour I meet people they come up to me
and they say man I'm part of the street
team and and that means so much to me so
I think I just wanted to to say thank
you for the street team could I make the
Wild Ride t-shirt zero
um
I think we just wildly expanded the
street team
that's good yes Grassroots marketing
right there right okay
um now
the uh
I I want to talk about the book
like uh I put out a book and
um I got really really upset because
um
the way that I promoted the pre-sale of
my book I said
the only way to buy a signed copy of the
hardcover version of my new book a hard
kick the nuts is to pre-order it I did
that because I wanted to to uh sell a
lot on the pre-order and and uh because
candidly when the book first comes out
on the publishing date that first week
all pre-order sales count to that first
week so if I sold
you know and like that's how you get on
the New York Times bestseller list
basically is you sell a bunch of
pre-sales you know or whatever you know
but it's it's a really helpful thing man
I I I hit it hard I promoted her on tour
like I uh I did this I signed off for
the pre-sale
um and I know
demonstrably that when that first week
happened in the book
I outsold multiple other books on the
New York Times bestseller list and they
[__] snubbed me it's a that guy like
the number of books it's like
and that that kills me you know that but
what killed me way more was that
I promoted the pre-order
saying that you can buy signed copies
for the pre-order but
um not all sellers
sold signed copies when I when I had
said that and I drove traffic to a page
the pre-order page had a bunch of
different sellers to choose from and it
was perfectly clear that not all of
those sellers were selling signed copies
but a large number of people clicked
Amazon pre-order not like looking and
just assumed that they were buying on
Amazon the signed copy but Amazon was
Amazon does not allow you to sell
anything that's autographed it's a rule
you can't do it so these people didn't
know that they pre-ordered the book on
Amazon and then when it showed up they
expected it to be signed it wasn't
signed they were pissed and they bashed
the book with one star ratings and I was
like I mean if anybody saw my video at
Knoxville they know how I feel about bad
ratings
and that's three stars
so I lost my [__] I absolutely lost
that's an understatement and it got it
it got uh even crazier because on the
Amazon you know who hasn't been on
Amazon and seen in the customer reviews
like response from seller it's like it's
like from seller and so I reached out to
the publisher and and I'm like hey
we need to respond to all of these
people who were disappointed that their
pre-ordered book was not signed and I
have the response be from seller and
they're like oh we can't do that and I'm
like wait a second I see this every day
from seller
you're telling me that you guys created
an Amazon storefront and it the name of
it is my name Stephen Stevo Glover and
the story's in my name and and I'm and
nobody has the ability to respond from
seller when every other seller on Amazon
seems to be doing that like no we can't
do it like Amazon it was a publication
you can't do that it turned out that it
was because of books but I just I was
and I was on the book tour when that
happened it was the first week and I was
going like on a five City [__]
massive tour and I said I'm going home I
said I'm on a flight to connect in
Chicago if this if uh if everybody isn't
responding tube by the time I land in
Chicago I'm not getting on the
connecting flight and I'm [__]
getting a new flight home I'm over it
I'm done [__] this and nobody could do
that everybody talked me off the ledge
what we ended up doing was getting
um Amazon to send emails to every single
person who pre-ordered which is very
rare very rare and uh sent them um
said that emails went out to every
single person who pre-ordered the book
and said and it was written by me saying
hey like there was a misunderstanding
here and I want to send you an official
collectible book plate which is a fancy
sticker which I sign that goes in the
inside cover making it an officially
signed copy and for you guys because
because this upset me so much I'm gonna
personalize every single one like 300
for the record everybody was like Steve
don't do that don't personalize it it's
a lot of work and you're like I don't
give a [__] dude these people mean so
much to me that I'm personalizing every
single one and and and at the time after
I sent out 300 of them each one
personalized this is so [__] funny
each I'm one of them is personalized
like uh you know we shipped them out of
the out of our warehouse nobody had to
pay for shipping [__] like uh we did
it all [__] every matched every
little name that we're shipping to plus
we even made sure the publisher to their
credit made sure that we knew what uh
purchased on Amazon yeah we knew we knew
like if we're shipping to somebody then
that's not the person that needs to be
made up for we made it we knew we made
sure we knew who to make it out to who
it was actually for and I sent out 300
of them
and then I looked at the uh after we
knew that they're all gone out they'd
all been received then I went back to
see if that improved the Amazon rating
and
it did it's because it's a good book but
but um
you know so the more information this is
getting improves over time but still
there are only 78 ratings I'm like I
sent out
[__]
300 of these things at least like
if you got my book on Amazon please
that's not more people with that anymore
uh and and dude the New York Times can
suck a fart out of my [__] man like
uh they they
um they just got bought out by Thrasher
that [__] Thrasher too I mean dude I
never want to write another book again
it's so much goddamn work like uh it's
stupid when I when I when I wrote that
book I delivered it and um got to uh you
know after delivering it I mean I was
having a nervous breakdown it was so
much goddamn work [__] writing that
book with a co-writer you know I asked
him because he was the same co-writer
that I made my first book with and this
was 10 years later and I I had him up
after we delivered the book I said dude
you've done nothing but write books
since we wrote our first one 10 years
ago out of all the people that you've
written books with in the last 10 years
did is there anybody who was so
meticulous about just like [__]
revisions and rewrites and everything he
says nobody was even close like and and
like I just took it so so seriously I
worked so [__] hard I almost had a
nervous breakdown and then delivered the
book and it was months before I went
into the studio to read the uh to read
the book aloud for the audiobook and and
being that many months removed from
actually being immersed in writing the
book like it was like I was looking at
this book that I delivered with fresh
eyes and I was having a [__] panic
attack in the goddamn audio recording
studio thinking why the [__] am I
admitting this why am I saying this it
is the most like insanely [__]
Reckless
honesty like there's like I do I paint a
picture of myself as a [__] terrible
piece of [__] in that book and it's just
like me telling the truth like uh where
can people buy it now I mean the audio
but the thank God I actually read the
whole book on audiobook there was a
scheduling debacle on the first book I
only read the first two chapters and
then some [__] [__] who's not me
is reading my story in the first
audiobook but um but I honored my word
even though the publisher is [__]
so pissed at me the publishing company
is so [__] furious at me that I will
not sell signed copies and I said dude I
said the only way to buy a signed
copy of the hardcover version is if you
pre-order it I can't say that and then
turn around and [__] start selling
signed copies so I'm never gonna [__]
sell a signed hardcover copy
like I mean the neck you know I do on
tour that counts that's what I said buy
a pre-order or the only way to get a
signed hardcover is without meeting me
in person
is to pre-order it because that count
coming to see my show as meeting me in
person so you can buy assigned
hardcovers on my tour
but I'm waiting for the paperback it's a
whole year I'll sign those are they uh
yeah but they can still buy a hardcover
autograph copy right now right
now I mean I think Barnes and Noble has
some left over but I'm not [__]
signing any more hardcovers because
that's not [__] pre-ordered okay then
what about
oh audiobook yeah go for it you'll sign
the audiobook no I'm not gonna sign out
of it but but like I never promoted the
first audiobook because I didn't read it
but I read this one we're going to buy
the audiobook it looks awesome man again
[__] you New York Times because this
book is awesome and it outsold you know
they didn't put this on non-fiction
because it's uh they call it a self-help
book which you know it's called like
what I learned from a lifetime of
terrible mistakes or terrible decisions
um and so they put it on the self-help
list which only has 10 titles on the
weekly New York Times list and I outsold
nine and ten so I should have been
number nine on the phone I'd sign my
numbers I should have been [__]
number nine they didn't put me on the
list they put two [__] books on the
list that sold less than mine
[__] ass crock of [__]
where can they buy the audio ah audio
you can get on anywhere you get audio
books okay cool absolutely anywhere and
and let's let's talk about something uh
uh more fun and interesting that like
let's stop bogging people down with the
minutia of business I wanna I wanna
[__] complain about the death penalty
that's what you have on your list I have
it on my list what's going on with the
death penalty I mean there's certain
things that I've I'm passionate about
and uh like if if uh podcasting without
a guest is gonna like be something that
we we do if we're gonna mix in
then we need to to have subjects to talk
about which uh are worth
getting into and I've set on here a lot
how much I I watched almost exclusively
Crime and Punishment on YouTube like on
uh on streaming platforms whatever
there's only one channel you watch
though right
I watch a million of them but there's
there's only one which is the gold
standard and that's JCS criminal
psychology and
JCS shouted me out on Twitter for
shouting him out on the podcast and I'm
just like dude I love this guy it's it's
Rad but
I pay attention to Crime and Punishment
I'm enthralled with stories about murder
and and interrogations and and trials
and I'm bringing this up
because I'm baffled and passionate
about it I'm baffled by how almost
universally every
convicted murderer
like well
do whatever they can like
plead guilty like um plead guilty in
that plea bargain the one thing that's
so important to them is to take the
death penalty off the table which is
like so ironic because like here they've
taken life but they're they but they're
clinging onto their own and I can't say
this with certainty but I think that
life in prison is like
better for people on death row for some
reason I think that you have like can
you look that up yeah dude the first
thing we've ever looked up on the wild
rice what are you talking about like
money wise I think like three meals a
day quality of life is is quality of
life better in prison if you're on death
row all right let me ask you this I
think there should be the death penalty
right I'll tell you why hold on I I
think there should be because it's a
probably deter a lot of people from
killing but if you were if you were like
one of the jurors on a trial and you had
a vote this guy guilty or not guilty and
they're like
um you know you vote the death penalty
or not I don't want to be the guy to be
like yeah kill this [__] guy so I
mean I just want to stand out of it and
not even okay and we've obviously never
had this conversation I guess because I
I'll never give anybody the death
penalty and I'll tell you why there's
two reasons and and they're completely
different reasons number one is
by the time you've executed a prisoner
you've exhausted every level of Appeals
all the way through the Supreme Court I
think it has to go all the way up to the
Supreme Court in order to execute
Somebody by the time you have gone
through that much appellate court
it has cost more in court costs to the
tune of 10 times more than it would cost
to just let that person live out their
natural Life Behind Bars and never get
out so just from uh an economic it is
economically [__] 10 times more
stupid to execute somebody than it is to
just leave them behind the you know
leave them locked up forever I mean if
somebody killed one of your family
members you wouldn't you would want to
see this guy locked up now you've
invited me to to the other point glad
you asked yeah okay
back in
2001.
I was in Cancun Mexico where every
single taxi driver is a cocaine dealer
Here We Go Again strap on your seat
belts because this is about to be
absolutely insane and I might add that
cocaine is bad habit okay I think we can
all agree on that and tell you the best
way to quit a bad habit is to replace it
with a good habit and man I've got this
new good habit it's called fume right
this has a uh core that's
got essential oil in it and there's it's
just essential oil and you breathe it
right like
there's all different flavors of the
essential oils and it handles the uh the
fidgety part of a bad habit where does
you just want to keep yourself busy you
know and
I'll tell you like
the The Habit that I think this is most
useful for I gave up 14 years ago but
I still like this and we talk about it
at length in this podcast later about
how I'm going around
inhaling my theme because I just like it
I literally just like it okay and that's
all there is to it and I think that not
only will you like it but I think it
will help you to give up a bad habit by
replacing it with this good habit and
that's why I want you to go to try
fume.com that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and when you do that
you're gonna get 10 off your order which
is a killer deal I like the mint just
straight mint they have different kinds
of myth like ah they got all kinds it's
epic and
I also have my buddy Vinnie who's got a
very bad habit and that is my gift to
you brother thanks dude and my gift to
everybody else is 10 off your order if
you go to
trifum.com Stevo now let's go into the
biggest rant ever
if they don't have the cocaine
underneath their their driver's seat
they'll just take you to the taxi stand
and get the cooking from someone who
does have it under their driver seat but
like literally to buy cocaine and Cancun
all you have to do is get in a taxi cab
and just say cocaine
um
I'm sitting there with the uh like I'm
an obnoxious amount of cocaine okay and
I'm in the hotel room and uh they're
they're they're uh executing the
Oklahoma City bomber Timothy McVeigh
yeah who it was in 1995 he blew up a
building and there's daycare in there I
mean there's never been a [__]
that anybody could more universally
agree deserve the death penalty this guy
blew up a whole [__] building and in
that building there was a daycare with a
bunch of kids in it he killed kids he
killed you know like like there's not a
more black and white argument for the
death penalty however
I was just sitting there alone doing
cooking and watching the [__]
coverage leading up to this guy's
execution all night all night
and it was on every [__] Network and
it was on every [__] Network even in
goddamn Mexico this guy was the most
famous [__] in the world on the N
that's all I ever wanted all I ever
wanted was to [__] be important to
[__] matter these these people are
[__] narcissistic as I am you know
like they just want [__] Fame and
attention and they don't care
so number one we were giving the guy
what he wanted okay now
they're it's just maddening that this
guy got some so much attention whereas
if he was just sitting behind [__]
bars for the rest of his life he would
never be important again just [__]
forget about it die Behind Bars and and
die in jail probably nobody's [__]
even gonna report that [__] whatever
you just you're here you you don't
matter now it gets way worse
because
on top of spending 10 times the amount
of money to kill this [__] piece of
[__]
they give him his his last meal request
right he can eat whatever the [__] he
wants for his last meal this [__]
[__]
God he got two tubs of mint chocolate
chip ice cream maybe two pints I don't
know but he had two of them
it's like okay so we catered to this
[__] [__] to have his two pints of
that's just offensive to me right okay
now what and then this is the really
this is the real [__] I bet he
they [__] uh he's allowed to have his
last words right you're allowed to have
your last words deliberately this guy
elected to not say his last words
Timothy McVeigh [__] wrote him down
on a piece of paper and he elected to
have a government official read his last
words aloud
so our taxpayer [__] money
on top of the [__] the the court
costs
paid for some [__] government
official to read these vile offensive
[__] words about how he is not sorry
how she is the master of his own domain
this [__] last words letter was the
most vile
offensive [__] [__] it makes the
[__] hair on my goddamn [__] stand up
and and and he and he had the
satisfaction of a government official
reading it out loud now it gets even
more offensive than that because in this
death chamber which [__] people are
hearing about all over the world there
were like
there were uh
different compartments there's a
different like one-way mirrors three of
them right yeah okay maybe
you think of this thing okay so he's in
it he's in this death chamber and
there's uh
like uh all one-way mirrors and there's
like I think three different rooms one
for
um government officials one for
um their family and his family
there's a family one family
um
there's uh government officials one and
there's a a media journalist one they
couldn't televise the actual killing
but they have a distinct room and a
separate room for journalists to to
witness The Killing and then go out of
the prison and and relate whatever what
it looked like now here's what happened
when they [__] killed this guy
there's three drugs
um yeah one puts you to sleep what what
one's general anesthesia one stops your
heart that stops your breathing
um
one of them definitely stops your heart
I think I think the other one's like uh
yeah yeah now by the time that this
first [__] oh I did this [__]
piece of [__] he goes he goes and sits
in his [__] thing maybe they strap
him down I don't know but he [__] this
is what the journalist described like
after the after the [__] guy was dead
it said he walked into the death chamber
[__] sat in his seat and and he he
like squinted looking at uh the first
one way because he can't [__] see it
it's a one-way glass you know it's a
one-way glass but he did his best to try
to look through each window and just
like you know like made some
disrespectful [__] like death to you
and then the next window tint you know
like he just made the disrespectful
gesture to each [__] window
and and by the way this is my
recollection of everything
at well over 20 years ago
but but like so and he like was just as
disrespectful as he could be to each
window right
whenever they read the [__] vile last
words and each [__] and then and then
imagine you're uh a [__] family
member and you want what you want you
want this [__] guy dead you [__]
you want Vindication this guy each
window whatever is [__] and then he
just [__] puts his head back they
said he didn't even [__] blink an eye
I don't even think I don't even think he
[__] blinked his eyes this [__]
[__] had the the best REM sleep of
his life dude it was it was it was
literally like like all the [__]
general anesthesia [__] that I've done
you know like it's like going in for
surgery to get [__] Hardware out of
your ankle you know without the pesky
part of where you wake up with the sore
ankle you know it was the most Cakewalk
[__] painless general anesthesia he
sat in it he disrespected everybody
[__] put vile words out was the most
famous [__] in the [__] world and
then put his head and had the most
painless comfortable death and [__]
it cost the it cost the taxpayers 10
times the amount of money for him to
have that satisfaction completely no
pain meanwhile the world is full of
people who are [__]
suffering
unspeakable Agony with terminal illness
and they're not allowed to have that
dignified painless death because
euthanasia is not legal they have to
[__] suffer in a hospice in horrible
[__] pain and they're not even
allowed to have meanwhile the one guy
who should have the [__] pain and the
[__] suffering gets the gets the
death of all those terminal patients
would beg for do you think that he would
be that pompous if the death penalty was
like we're gonna rip your limbs off and
then your [__] dick off you know I
mean it wasn't so like painless I don't
know I don't know but what like now we
come back to why it's so baffling to me
that it's so important to all of these
piece of [__] murderers that death
penalty be taken off the table like
don't don't take you to the bodies
they'll they'll they'll [__] show you
where the body's buried they'll [__]
admit to everything just for the love of
God don't give me what Timothy McVeigh
got you know I don't get it I think the
stats were like to to house a prisoner
in jail is like 36 000 a year but the
house uh somebody on Death Rows like 120
a year or something like that I mean I I
wouldn't be surprised
and I wouldn't be surprised if that also
did not include the core costs yeah
well that's cool
it would be it would be cool to have
somebody on death row as a guest of the
podcast I've absolutely been dying but
we can't do it in California in
California because you can't have a
inmate in California on camera if
anybody's listening that has access to a
death row inmate elsewhere no that would
be great the Nevada I would love to
[__] interview somebody on death row
yeah somebody gone listening can make
that happen please make that happen
so I'm looking at cost 64k a year in
California to house a prisoner what
about somebody on death row
our first
time I've been I've been doing this the
whole time nobody's looking kind of
because it's uh the wire's out look I
have Timothy McVeigh up what's PornHub
we tried our best
um
I uh don't even know where we put it's
like an ad reads on this podcast I'm
sure they've already all right before
death row
um Vinnie I didn't give you we talked
about Paul but I've got Paul and Vinnie
on here
um there's no HDMI in yeah dude please
we failed on that wouldn't worry about
that in the future
um
it's what we failed on is the bringing
up uh with the [__] multimedia on the
TV in here
um I had Paul and Vinnie and I just
can't stand enough Vinnie you're a star
thanks man you know like um good vibe
good energy good vibe good energy Rider
[__] die ride or die baby yeah ride
or die and uh yeah the three podcasts we
did in Texas Vinnie drove the [__]
car out there we're like we're like dude
who can we get to drive the thing it was
like Vinnie call them up Vinnie would
you wanna drive the car to Texas he's
like I'm on my way Dad
I love that that uh I don't have to
worry about setting up demand Vinnie
does it
um I loved having you on the mic on the
uh
yeah Zach was none too pleased I mean I
don't know
I can't speak to that
um
but dude you're a solid guy you're so
you're a song thanks dude and um I try
if you're great on the mic on the Zack
podcast you've been great on the mic on
this one
and um
I I don't know but uh but but if if this
was a tryout as well as the Zach one
your tryouts are going well [__] yeah
except for the yeah and if you were to
become like the Jamie of this podcast
start off by [__] stopping this
goddamn thing going to sleep okay that'd
be pretty sick okay we failed miserably
on uh on the multimedia but but uh
um okay uh giveaways let's give away
some more [__] uh we got those Tony Hawk
boards okay uh back to the how do people
get a hold of you to get these [__]
shoes dude here's the thing is like
in 2000 back in the 80s how long did it
take you to get a hold of Motley Crew
now people can just like FaceTime chat
me from Instagram and be like uh could
Steve kick me in the nuts
can you do me a tattoo it's like
okay get creative I think uh I'll save
that get older Isaac dude is our new guy
right you know what like I won't save it
I want to [__] complain about how
many [__] people have been have
brought up the me meeting Motley Crew
when I was a kid and trying to compare
it to what they were doing like uh dude
and like it's just like you meeting
Monica and like no there's like
backstage at your tour bus that says
Stevo on it like right like like no
because
because I
called hotels I didn't [__] contact
the band I went
calling the rooms of asking for the
band's manager how many phone calls do
you think you made that day yeah I I
mean at least 100 at least 100 and it
was an invasive [__] piece of [__]
[__] thing to do but I didn't care I
did it anyway you know like I wanted
what I wanted and I went after it like
[__] with it but don't like don't
compare like
what I did was uh was one thing and and
all too often people compare what
they're doing to that and it's just not
comparable but I'll tell you what is the
most [__] impressive and Vinnie
probably doesn't know the story this is
the most [__] impressive thing a kid
ever did and it is absolutely on the
[__] level of what I did for Motley
Crue and it's actually way more clever
when I burned myself up and had the skin
graft surgery in 2017. I'm [__]
like I'd been I I was in so much fun
I've been more pain than I'd ever been
in my life it actually made something in
my brain snap and I just turned into a
[__] psychosis maniac and then the
surgery made the pain go away and I woke
up with more gratitude than I'd ever had
and I was in Denver
getting ready to fly home with all my
bandages on and I thought it was so
notable I was like dude this is such a
big deal that I went and posted on my my
social media saying dude like got out of
surgery I'm so grateful [__] like I'm
fixed and like if any Paparazzi want to
um [__] meet me at the airport like
I'm I'm on flight so and so flying from
Denver to L.A like I posted my flight
info I've never done that at one time I
did that so as I'm walking through the
airport in Denver
like over the [__] loudspeaker in the
the airport
um [__]
it says would Mr Stephen Glover please
pick up a courtesy phone like uh you
know for a message no way yeah and I'm
like I remember being like like at that
time like Stills on some [__]
psychosis [__] dude something [__] I
was like dude this can only be good news
it's gonna be so rad I go over to a
courtesy phone I'm picking up I'm like
hello the guy was like dude is this
Stevo and I'm like [__] yeah it is who's
this he's like oh dude what Steve was he
in uh he was he was in some [__]
Idaho Dakota like he was not in Colorado
at all and he's like he's like dude you
post your flight info and I figured
you'd be walking through the airport
right now so I called the airport and
asked him to page you
yeah and I'm like that's the most
[__] awesome
holy [__] yeah that was not we flew the
guy out did we we tried to and then he
was there with his dad then he had a red
carpet thing to go to and he couldn't do
it I don't know if we flew him out it
was we stayed in contact with him no he
came out to LA and we were like dude
come to the yeah contact with them he's
like oh he's like dude I'm coming out to
L.A and we're like [__] dude let me come
to the red carpet thing for something or
other like I think it's a game over man
game over man like [__] red carp let
us let us [__] [__] you're the most
impressive guy let us show you the best
time that we possibly can yeah the kid
like was stoked then he was like oh man
you know my dad and I were kind of just
[__] doing this now he's never even
been bothered
you're just like was empty bless his
heart because the kid [__] has a life
and he's got his own interests and
[__] just was too busy doing [__]
that he was stoked on to even bother
meeting up with us but we did get to
ultimately meet him in person when he
made it to one of our shows on tour at
the show that's rad
and that's the other thing that's the
other thing is that that kid
that kid would never go up and say dude
it's just like when you met Molly Crew
because if you do something impressive
like that you're not [__] yeah it's
impressive in its own right you don't
have to try to [__] compare it to
something else to make it seem
impressive it's either impressive or
it's not and that [__] kid calling
the airport was bad ass that's sick all
right so but what do you want to give
away
um
okay so your shoes the the right person
will do the right thing they'll do the
right thing but then again whoever
impresses you will get yeah some shoes
that you don't even know what they are
what are they high top Jordan Ones black
and yellow okay what'd you pay for them
I think like 300. all right that's cool
um what about the the we got some boards
in there the uh the Tony Hawk boards
Stevo Tony Hawk there's things where
they're that's the only numbered
limited edition item that we ever did we
did 500 of them we wanted to be really
careful because we knew we couldn't do
more than 500 we wanted to be super
careful that we didn't like uh run out
and run out or like sometimes you get
lost in transit or UPS deals that are
FedEx whatever so we only sold 450 of
them
leaving 50 that uh we've given away to
like special things I think we have a
little 11 left yeah like uh Tony Hawk
gets some we still haven't given them
the ones yeah so we've got some for Tony
Hawk and of what's left over we've got
like 11. I mean whatever dude those
things are are gonna be it's rad to have
something that valuable I would just say
that like uh maybe we'll pick some
random people that that get the free
pins we'll throw it in there they're
numbered limited numbered and signed by
both me and Tony Hawk and it's a
skateboard with the image of us doing
the double wall ride it's so sick let's
give away let's give away one of them
okay we'll give away one of them also I
think would be cool is one of our
sponsors is athletic greens I'll give
away all buy a month supply for somebody
if they can get a hold of me okay so if
you get a hold of me I'll give you a
month's Supply the other sponsored theme
I should say this on the Adrian perfume
but uh I love this [__] dude I literally
[__] puff on a farm thing and it
throws everybody off because I'm not a
cigarette smoker I haven't smoked
cigarettes and [__] like 14 years
um but I just I just like it so I'm
[__] like uh that is no nicotine it's
not nicotine at all there's no nothing
there's nothing it's just Vapor oh no
this is a core with essential oil maybe
that's something I should try yeah why
are you smoking cigarettes no vaping
dude get on fumed [__] baby I [__]
hate it dude I love doing it man like uh
I enjoy it and and it's not bad for me
yeah and uh you know like Lux thinks
that you know that it's lame because I'm
not you know it's definitely not as lame
as [__] vaping and it's a really good
way to get off vaping yeah like I need
that yeah let's hook you up with that
um and the other one is uh the other
podcast sponsor is better help and it's
so important to have somebody to talk to
and if you don't have anybody to talk to
I mean you can go and better help and
get somebody to talk to you because
there's people that dude just to get
that [__] out is like yeah what a
[__] relief dude and if and if you
don't and you're holding that [__] in
it's like then like weird OCD Twitches
happen or like all of a sudden you're
[__] blowing up at somebody in
traffic and it has nothing to do all of
a sudden you're sending your hateful
texts yeah
that's how we kind of got into this is
like uh I mean yeah I I I've been in a
[__] rough spot like well you you you
sent a a rough text to somebody then I
sent a hateful text sorry if I just
interrupted you and I know that this
that that sucks and [__] on me if you
want but you're gonna keep going anyway
I said I've sent a hateful text and and
you bless your heart I'm so grateful for
you the way you reacted to it
you said okay what's really going on
well because it wasn't like you you're
not mean to people like you don't the
one thing I the one thing I will say
about you is like you don't gossip about
other people behind their back and you
don't like you're you're not like mean
to people you've never been you've never
been like that like dude I'll gossip and
I'll talk [__] the people behind their
back it's just kind of what I do and
it's you know but I don't I don't mean
it but like it was just out of context
for you and I was like you know what's
really going on if you're doing that
because that's that is my therapist will
always say like dude what they look for
is incongruent patterns
it's like you're saying one thing you're
doing it like something's off right and
like the that thing that sits on
people's desks sometimes where it's like
four balls and they're all hanging yeah
from a string and you pull back one ball
but what fires off is the fourth ball
down
so you got one thing bothering you
that's the first ball and then what you
actually go up about what you actually
go up about is the four the fourth ball
down so like the hateful text I wrote
what was not what was bothering me yeah
the hateful text I wrote was the fourth
ball down and when you asked me okay
what's really going on you're asking me
to identify what's the first ball that
got pulled back well dude I won't say
you we won't talk about who but you said
eat [__] and I was like I misspelled it
because
I misspelled it twice
in the last decade of working with you
I've never heard you say that to anybody
I know I don't think I I can't remember
the only time I've ever seen you be mean
to somebody was when you're cycling and
you're like you flipped off a car and I
was like damn duty is really passionate
about cycling
I remember like you got like aggressive
cycling I think you gave me too much
credit but no no but you've never been
like oh [__] you you that's not you
right
I'll tell you what we didn't do we did a
little bit of year in review this next
year
I'm uh
I'm committed to feeling better about
like what I serve
to my audience I'm not gonna stop trying
to get the bag because I got a lot of
people who [__] count on me man I got
a lot of people who are depending on me
I've got a lot of businesses that uh
like I don't want to have fail
and I've got a a pretty shocking over it
I've got shocking overhead yeah bam
hey hi
hey what's up okay here we have one one
sec
um all right with that we're gonna we're
gonna wrap it up and leave a comment if
you liked having no guest on us talking
[__] yeah that was cool thanks guys okay
sweet
all right
how about that folks the first episode
with no gas I was really like wanting to
do that for a long time and I was
terrified of doing it and now that we
did it I think that was like rad I think
that was a really rad one and I think
that we could do it like many times more
and have it be equally rad if not rather
so man please I would love it if the
street team could uh speak up and tell
us a few things and I promise I'll try
to be better about [__] and talking
over people and not letting them talk
and and
what can I say but check it out
everybody it's Paul who knows where the
[__] in the world he is now where
some place called so
um evidently Paul's not at the house say
hi dude you're in the mic
oh yeah hello everybody miss you guys
good to see you yeah and uh and check it
out [__] makes make the magic happen
on the computer dog show us how see
Paul's a [__] Music musician so check
him out he's in here with the sound
waves come on make it look crazy dude
come on dude like just cleaning up the
audio I got he's running the computer
from some [__] country
you're not the country might be called
Indiana I don't know
it but it's not [__] California
looking we don't wear scarves in fact in
California anyway dude I love you Paul
too yeah if there's any speculation
about a conspiracy then
again
you know here's the gorgeous Paul
Briskey love you thank you everybody and
I'm gonna bone my lady